said rafael today is an immeasurable pain
and you felt there like you were her
person at that moment you are with
that feeling the breathing of fatigue
the publican heart and that sadness
Also, you end up absorbing yourself.
can
[Music]
violence is directed by poor
who are young people of
community and young people from the periphery
marginalized by that state in the person
of the military police officer that we
the person getting out of her comfort zone
that she is aware of what is
happening around you
Fight this violence to end
[Music]
there is an attempt I think the
own traditional media makes and is
to trivialize the violence of trivializing
of trivializing death and sometimes
that in the story of those who suffer
loss sufferer this account account contains
may never have been heard like this
experience provides the reaction
end is a hug is a is a contact is 11
recognition of that other
A place like that for a beer.